[Music]
like most the time it's like we kind of
have like social scripts to follow your
you know you come in here you say hello
and then if something kind of just goes
out of the ordinary it just it just kind
of shakes us up and makes us feel kind
of uncertain and there is a long stretch
of scientific literature on this dating
back to the 1960s there's this classic
study where they they shocked people and
these little like electric shocks and
they asked people if they preferred
shocks when they knew they were coming
or if they preferred shocks that kind of
just came out of nowhere and people
would rather know when the little
painful shock was coming so which kind
of is interesting to me because you
would think that the expectation might
make it worse but but we like
predictability I guess so I think that's
one of the reasons why it's interesting
that sometimes we call awkwardness
painful or excruciating that kind of
adds an interesting layer to that so a
big part of my kind of cringe theory is
kind of what I'm calling it is there is
a difference we don't like to pay
attention to it very much or I don't but
there is a difference often between the
way that you see yourself and the way
that you think you're presenting
yourself to the world and the way that
the rest of the world is perceiving you
and it's something that really helped
unlock this for me was the idea it's
almost like a cliched thing that people
hate the sounds of their own voices or
people don't like looking at you know
recordings of themselves and in
particularly the the thing that about
people hating the sound of their own
voices is a great example of this
because your voice really does sound
different to you than the way everyone
else is hearing you so when when we hear
somebody talk you're you're kind of like
hearing someone else through like the
air but when I'm hearing myself talk I'm
hearing myself through the air and
through the bones of my own skull which
actually transmits the sound differently
and makes my voice sound lower than
actually is
so it's a really common complaint people
are like they listen to their own voices
and they're like oh my gosh like it's so
much higher than I thought it was that's
always what I think about when I hear my
own voice played back and I think that
this is a central part of my theory
about what makes us cringe is when the
you you think you're presenting to the
world kind of clashes with the you the
world is actually seeing and that makes
us uncomfortable because we like to
think that we're coming off in a certain
way and it's just like oh no like that's
that's what you think of me like that's
that's how you see me
and I think that's never gonna go away
there's always going to be there's this
this psychologist Philippe Rochat
at Emory University who has a name for
this he calls this the irreconcilable
gap and so he he really thinks it's even
in the name it's never gonna go away
there's always gonna be this gap between
the way you perceive yourself and the
way others perceive you and I think
that's at the heart of what we call
awkward moments or awkwardness kind of
that uncomfortable feeling that you're
cringing at yourself or at somebody else
if you it takes a while but you can
start to train yourself to think of that
as a useful piece of information if you
like try to like negotiate a raise or
like negotiate a promotion at work or
something and it kind of makes us
uncomfortable too when your boss is like
oh actually like you know I see you in
this light you know it's not something
we want to hear or if you say something
and someone takes it as an insult and
you didn't mean it that way but the
other person took it that way and that
kind of makes you feel awkward or makes
you feel self-conscious or cringe at
yourself you you could just tell
yourself what the other person the other
person's perception of you doesn't
matter it's not true you know you and
that's that's it but I've started to
think that it's useful sometimes to take
the other person's point of view into
mind they're not always right like it
would be insane to suggest that other
people know you better than you know
yourself but one way I've figured out of
how to deal with this emotion a little a
little better is to
just start thinking about as useful
information like maybe this is a way
maybe this is a way to start tiptoeing
towards becoming this person did I see
myself as this person that I wish I was
like kind of the you know nerdy
definition of humor is kind of like an
up ended expectation and that's what so
many of these awkward embarrassing
moments are you thought something was
gonna go this way you thought you were
coming across this way and whoops no
like this other thing happened this
other person sees you in a totally
different light and I think if you can
start to think of these moments as a
little bit funny it helps to and maybe
to eventually turn it into a story you
can tell somebody else I guess I have
two thoughts about awkward embraces I
mean I came across a lot of them and
kind of made myself to do some
awkwardness embracing books too but one
that comes to mind is there's this guy
Stefan
Hoffman at he's a he's a therapist in
Boston and he runs this social anxiety
clinic and people who have social
anxiety like feel awkward as' to the
extreme you know they're very
self-conscious and just it really it
just prevents them from from living you
know I'm from from a lot of
opportunities and just a lot of
happiness and so his whole therapy is
designed around making people experience
awkwardness like like having people
dream up like what would be the most
embarrassing thing I can think of to do
and then he's like great okay now go do
that uh and so if you've had people do
things like like go into a bookstore and
ask a clerical excuse me I am looking
for books about farting or you've had
people like you know go up to tables at
a restaurant like at a nice restaurant
and say like excuse me I am working on
my maid of honor speech may I practice
it for you just these horrible things
and the point is to kind of put them
through like they're worse like social
nightmares and then you know
to have them come out the other side and
be like Oh like I survived like people
looked at me weird but like I survived
and a lot of times it wasn't as bad as
they thought it was I think I think
because his whole thing is framing this
with with humor too he really wants
people to take themselves less seriously
which is again just a lesson I'm
constantly having to learn not to teach
myself so seriously and then the other
the other kind of like monthly ritual in
putting yourself in an awkward situation
is this thing I came across called
mortified which is this this stage show
it's all across the country all across
the world where people get up on stage
and read from their teenage journals
which just like I but I first came
across this was like why that and then I
did it it kind of I almost did it you
know a lot of things the book I almost
did just like as a a stunt like oh I'll
do this now and it'll be funny and
almost every time every time I was
surprised by how much I kind of got out
of it like getting up on stage and
reading from my middle school journal I
it's in a weird way you would think even
think of getting up there and reading
some of the most embarrassing things
you've ever thought would end up making
you feel really alone and really
isolated and really stupid but it ends
up it ended up making me feel like
really weirdly like connected to
everybody else who's been in the show
and everybody in the audience I think
every time it's a comedy show and so
it's like it's it's done pull out of
compassion but it's also it's also
really funny and when you get to a line
where you read something that you wrote
as a you know really angsty
twelve-year-old it makes everyone laugh
it feels really good because a lot of
times people laugh because they
recognize themselves in you and so if
they're recognizing themselves in you
then then you're not alone like you're
you're embarrassing things aren't
started they don't have to isolate you
and so I ended up getting out of this
whole awkwardness like deep study this
like common humanity vibe I was not
expecting
[Music]